I was just wondering if you wanted to um
you know go out sometime you want to get
a coffee now yes now
I'll just hang on
when I wake up well I know I'm gonna be
her name is Sadie
I mean I know this sounds crazy I think
she might be the one who
goes along with you she really is great
you'll see
any word she goes to them I bet she
hasn't even seen your text she does
travel a lot for work go to her I'm
going to London
see you get it it's a grand romantic
gesture that is amazing mate 5 000 miles
as far as a girl you've only met once
especially if she's the one who ghosted
yeah
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan all right
[Music]
all right
where am I oh God you you have the wrong
guy I'm a former wait wait
[Music]
foreign
oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I saw the rock
you're the one who flew to London
it was a romantic gesture
get every bumpy Hunter on the cockpit I
want her life
this is bigger than you and me
it never occur to you that he could be a
foreign asset trying to compromise your
mission
foreign
[Music]
trust me is that a joke